this is a production of Cornell
University
okay thank you and thank you dear for
the instruction and also thinking are
everybody for coming to my talk so
here's the title of my talk
understanding the molecular mechanisms
underlying illuminant resistance in plan
so my topic is about aluminum toxicity
aluminum toxicity is tightly associated
with a sequoia the reasons that aluminum
is the most abundant metals on the earth
crust and the neutral ph aluminum is
tightly bound to the soil claims which
is a non-toxic to plan however under a
sexual condition the toxic illuminant
species so that's al three plus is will
release from the soil claimed into soil
solution which is highly toxic to Helen
Andrew grow here shows the map of word
as the Sawyer's so you can see the a/c
soy which is in red color is widely
distributed around the world with a
significant fraction in the Devourer
developing countries in the topic and
subtropics so there is really need to
understand the molecular mechanisms
underlying or magazines underlying
aluminum resistant in crops in order to
further enhance resistance to assess oil
for car
so this slide shows the toxic effects of
aluminum on to read line so when it's
our ETA that's aluminum current and
esate is a little insensitive as you can
see under neutral pH there's no
difference in google between these two
lines however and the essex or air
conditioning can see this sensitive like
the lugals was completely inhibited with
stunted and damaged root growth so the
problem of aluminium toxicity is so
privileged in developing country so it
is the major limitation for crop
production on icy soil so also from this
line can see that genetic variation in
terms of illuminant resistance so this
is our focus for our study and this is
also the our basis for perm breeding
purposes so in today's talk i will first
briefly introduce the strategies adopted
by plans to cope with a luminance yes
and then i will highlight some efforts
in my group to unveil how plants use
these strategies to achieve illuminant
resistance
okay so here's the diagram another plant
so this is the room and the about when
our part and this part is a magnificent
of the route if luxury the root tip
region so root tip is the target for
illuminant toxicity so it's most
sensitive to a luminance Jess so here is
the rhizosphere and here's a diagram for
the good epidermal cells with a plasma
membrane the membrane of vacaville and a
sale world so the widely and most
documented Magnusson's for illuminant
resistance is the exclusion or avoidance
avoidance Magnussen's which prevents
illuminant from getting into other route
sales so this is done by the release our
route sales of organic acids such as
made lately chase into the erasers
fields where the organic as you can form
non-toxic OA aluminum home class that
cannot be getting to the sale so it's
like exclusion so that's the first
magazines the second magnet up the
second mechanism to deal with the
illuminant that enters into the other
root cells so this aluminum can be
either sequestered into the vacuolar or
can be translocated from the root to the
shoot so the shoes is the last sensitive
to illuminance Jess so recently
increasing lines of evidence indicate
that modification of resale world
structure and function could be a
critical step for illuminant resistance
in plans so I also focus on that in
might later talk
so here comes the second part of my talk
so I will highlight some errors in my
group for for the alumina exclusion
mechanisms in slogan and true aluminum
resistant are in a bird offices and
finally I will report on some of our
progress in understanding the regulatory
or signaling pathway involving resistant
to low pH and illuminance yes in air
toxics so here comes the first product
so these shelves are the real growth of
two sorgen lines one is tolerant as the
283 and the sensitive BR 0 7 on the low
ph plus illuminant solution so you can
see the root growth of the tauren lines
has no effect but you can see stunted
and damaged renewed for the sensitive
line and this is the work done by dura
mcgaughys so he's the former PhD student
haha for Leah and now he's a close
collaborator for our group also so also
he found that the the very close
correlation between the aluminum
activated secret released from the
torrent line and aluminum resistant so
there's no all organic acid release from
the sensitive right was the return line
and this line is very sensitive so
here this summary for the relationship
between a room intolerance and rude
situated east so here shows the the
torrent line growth with our without
illuminance that it's the control and
the treatment in a period of six days
aluminum treatment so you can see the
first day the root growth are even for
the repeal of the torrent line so it was
inhibited by about fifty percent
compared to the control so it continued
up being inhibited advanced level but on
the third day of treatment you can see
our gradually increase of root growth
and by the fourth day you see there is
no difference between the treatment and
the control and this process is very
closely and positively correlated with
the rude CJ release in the torrent line
socially without illuminant you don't
see any securities but with illuminant
so we are you can see gradually in
touching of such a release so by that i
mean the third day there's much more CJ
release and this correspondent to the
increase of root growth so by the ton of
the sixth day at the huge amount of such
a release from the rooted and you can
see fully recovery of the root growth in
a torrent line in conscious in the
sensitive life you never seen any
situation from the root with orbital
aluminum and actually the root growth
never recover from the achievement and
based on that a juror heated a killed a
mapping project and he actually mad
the illuminant resistant locals into one
single bag so then I are coming to
leon's lair and juara graduate and also
we further a collab on collaborate on
that project and also by the way I mean
he also did the correlation analysis for
situate release and aluminium tolerance
for a small panel of sorgen service 10 a
section what he found is the sea trade
release is positively correlated with
our aluminum torrance among the this
section and also so we finally calonge
the gene the resident gene it encodes a
sorghum a member of sorgen motto jug and
parsley compound institution so genes
that we demonstrate that so this SP mate
gene actually encode the aluminum
activated CJ transporter in in sorghum
and the expression of SB may is
positively correlated with aluminum
torrents as well as CJ release in the
same certain session panda I mentioned
in the previous slide
so here comes the problem so what is a
shader for using sea trade as a weapon
for a luminary season it's very
obviously that's a carbon cost so so for
plans best benefit is to use minimum
amount of CJ to achieve measurement
illuminant tolerance so let's deal with
the carbon use efficiency are so how can
you can achieve this the one way is to
specify the expression of SB mate gene
expression so we can see SB maze is only
it's made expressed in the real tip
region so that's the region most
sensitive to aluminum and gets the one
that need most protection and not only
that I mean if you we also do the amino
localization and LCM the laser
dissection microscope are real time pcr
actually the SB made protein and
transcription is only expressed in the
very defined region like epidermal cells
and the first layer of cortex so that's
defined the situated leaves only in that
part of the pen root tissue so is that
enough so the question is not the
reasons that the asteroid is on in red
is not a homogeneous yeah poverty
actually is quite heterogeneous in
distribution so here shows a an acid
soil are filled in Australia so the red
color indicate that are the soils are
highly acidic but you see it not far
away I mean there's some
some sort region that's hot either
neutral or even alkaline so so that's in
the XY dimension if you look at the the
third dimension the vertical dimension
so you can see also vary a lot of
valuation usually I mean the top lawyers
are less illuminant to succeed and the
deep sale are deep soil and also when
the plants grow from the top soil into
the deep soil so the principles are
gross as they tip growth manner so
whenever he goes it's like constantly
meet our the change of soil environment
so the question is how do plan routes
sends the frequent changes in aluminum
toxicity and how it react so that's the
question we want to adjust and
so to answer this question in in so can
I actually are transformed the SPM a
gene into East ezel has no harm alog of
spm a gene in the genome so without
illuminant you see no are with OB de
iluminación sino are situate release
which is media bite as we made but with
the SB mate expression is that you can
see the our concerted activity is our
release of CJ with or without aluminum
so this is a very different of what we
have seen in our slogan so which are so
this situated ease is actually activated
only activated by a luminous jest so now
release are under control so this
suggests that must have some negative
regulator for SB made are in pines so
that's lead to that tube and my second
work here so so I think and then I
decided to use the spirit ubiquitin is
two hybrid systems so because because I
use that are because as we made is a
membrane proteins I have to use this
brief ubiquitin sister is to Highbury
system to screen are a library that may
from the source organ rooted and I found
a very own candidate are interacting
protein so it's a putative metal binding
protein so here we call in our as a MBP
as a strong candidate for the RS be made
interacting component so what happened
if we call transformed
this two component into East actually we
see the reconstitution of aluminium
activated situate release everything are
in sorgen so here is the single as we
made our chance transform and we see
constituent large among a seat release
was the are very controlled and aluminum
activated situated ease in the arm
double transforming so the question is
the sitter is the I mean of organic acid
that binds to a luminance there is a
foundation for a luminary system so what
what's the aluminum tolerance of this to
line with this one has higher amount of
situated ease can achieve higher degree
of aluminum resistant or not so here is
the next experiment for testing relative
growth or aluminum torrents for three
different East line so is the East just
transform with empty vector so you see
that's very sensitive to aluminum but
the single transform that are the girls
geometry increase is not as good as the
double transform so we remember I mean
this line has huge amount of scituate
release so bottaro it could be rich rich
are higher degree of aluminum resistant
but actually is not the reasons that the
carbon cost that's too much and then
actually inhibit our circle
very sensitive so here comes our the
working model for how these two
components work together to achieve a
lumen activated situation sedation so
here is the plasma membrane of the root
epidermal cells and as we may is a
situation sporter and MVP is a negative
regulator for SB mate so without
illuminant it titled it binds to the
permeation pathway of the situation's
border so which can block the seat
release from sale are the cytosol into
rice field and npp is a aluminum binding
protein and the acidic soil condition
you are impeded binds to aluminum and
change its conformation and also its
affinity to SB may will be decreased and
this will lead to dissociation or
partial dissociation of MVP from the SP
may so leading to opening of the
situation sedation premier permeation
pathway so lead into the education of
citrate release ok so so this would be
to to adjust this mother we need to
confirm yet three things one is any
piece of aluminum binding protein and
also the binding to aluminum can disrupt
the our MVP and SB made interaction so
here's the work by michael lee also i
think is also indeed audion and so
here's the poor down SI to demonstrate
that our MVP is a ph-dependent aluminum
binding protein so here is just the
beads you see there's no finding of
to our two binding of the MBP to the
beads so that means any binding here
it's a specific and also are under the
treatment we only see the binding of MVP
to our aluminum the aluminum beads at a
low pH but not in the neutral pH so
that's confirmed that MBP it's a
ph-dependent aluminum binding protein
and second we need to demonstrate that
aluminum binding to MVP can disrupt MVP
and SB made interaction so here is the
in vitro poured an essay so you can see
under the neutral pH so it with with the
impressions or in absence of aluminum so
there's always still interaction between
s be made and SB MVP here right however
and the long pH without illuminant we
can see a little bit decrease of
interaction of this two component but
when illuminance was added you see
there's no interaction that mean that's
completely dissociated reading this to
our two component so that's in vivo and
then I did are the in vivo vif see our
interaction so that's the assistant that
tested for interaction of two are
proteins if there's protein protein
rushing you will see fluorescent and if
the introduction was disrupted you will
see decrease of the fluorescence signal
so so that's the RBI FC and then this
movie shows what happened after aluminum
was added so this is the tobacco
epidermal leave cell
yeah I mean it's quite rapid process
about two and half hours you see almost
completely disappearing of the
fluorescent so ok what's the controls
that this'll control that just eject the
buffer but without a lumen and with the
same period time of recording
yes see the difference of so that
demonstrate that are the interaction of
aluminum I mean our SPM a 10bp was
disrupted by adding aluminum so so in
previous slide we demonstrate that MBP
is a aluminum binding protein and
binding of aluminum could cause
dissociation of MBP and SB mate
intelligence so pretty much demons are
confront our hypothesis
so here comes the the second of part so
it's deal with the two torrents in
epitope six so so is this part so deal
with in remove illuminant from sale war
into cytosol so sell is a very important
organ air for our in aluminium tolerance
so it's estimated that ninety percent of
the illuminant in jewels was accumulated
in sale world so increasing number of
our increasing numbers lines of evidence
indicate that modification of cell wall
components could be a very important
place a very important rule in
illuminaries systems so the to torrance
Magnusson's inward like two parts one is
move illuminant into the arm cytosol
offered by our secret sir sequestration
into the back here or translocated into
the above-ground tissues so in fact in
implants there's a specific class of
that actually they like aluminum so this
the so-called illuminant accumulator
plant species so including like Artie
buckwheat and hygiene gia so they tend
to uptake large amount of aluminum from
the sawyer and translocated into the
shoot tissue and store the aluminum in
the baculum so so this photo shows hi
gentle plans are in front of wegmans in
the nest over here screen yeah so you
can see their arm the some intense
produce our blue flowers were some
something's red flowers I can tell you
they all have the same genetics so that
means the flowers are color change is
due to environment environmental effects
but not genetic difference actually sort
of it's only are assisting of Sawyer so
the the one on the left the screw in the
acid soil so that produce are the blue
flower was the neutral ph s are so you
see that are produced red flower
so so here's a close up for the very
beautiful lighting here and actually
that only difference is a group in Japan
the other horticultural they actually
analyze what's going on here they found
that actually they are only difference
for for the these two flowers that are
this one the blue one they accumulate
high amount of aluminum in the sea pearl
I mean that what we see actually Sasebo
is not pattern it was the art that the
red red cauliflower and then actually
they are the reason is that under
neutral pH so this the enter dining
accumulated in the back ever so called
out there finding 30 Google side so it's
has a native red color but and the soy
are as acidic soil conditions illuminant
would be accumulated into the vacaville
which combines to the enter dining and
turn is color into blue does the
cigarette of that magic and actually
they clone this to our transporter so
one is responsible for the moving of
aluminum into the cytosol so that plasma
membrane localized record a part or
plasma membrane localized aluminum
transporter and the one responsible for
vacuolar transporter is called what or
vacuolar illuminant transporter both
these genes are belong to our the
aquaporin gene family so aquaporin it's
a very large gene family implants so
like they have 35 members in every top
six and 33 in rise
and also I copart intend to transport
neutral so long and because I also i
mean our port and what are the first
members of aquaporin demonstrate that
our be able to transport aluminum so
that's the interesting for us are
working an illuminant resistance so the
question although they demonstrate that
this genes functioning aluminum
transporter but they we don't know if
they have any function in aluminum
torrance implant and because the part is
the plasma membrane localized our
illuminant transporter and which is it
could be a critical component for
aluminum uptake in in rules so I decided
to focus to studied the report homologue
in Alberta physics and HM pod is closely
related to the NIP subfamily in our in
arabidopsis nip stands for the Nigerian
26-inch in zeg floating so this the work
was start lead led by eg one
and also we screen the middle library
for the nine-member of the NIP nips in
epic opsys and found out that nip one
touch to actually has the hypersensitive
phenotype are two illuminance just when
expressed in east so here's the control
and the treatment and also we include
included Android one so it's a famous
illuminant transporter are localized in
the rule sale plasma membrane so this
world are being done by a genial Indians
group and we can see hypersensitive of
nip one dash two to aluminum but it's
the sensitivity is not as young as arm
the Android one indicated that probably
I mean the nip one touch to the capacity
is lower than Andrew everyone in tons of
aluminum transport and also which it has
the alumina accumulation in the three
East line we can see on the hyper
accumulation of aluminum in the nip one
touch to to expression East line but the
amount is not as high as are the Android
one further indicating that the capacity
of nip one dash two transported our
lumen transporter might be it's lower
than and red one also each it has the
subcellular localization of nip one
dodge tool he made the grp fusion
protein and this slide shows the
localization of diffusion protein so
it's in the plasma membrane and this
further demonstrate by the
type a type I stay so it's very clear
localized on the plasma membrane for
this protein and nip one dash two is
emily's made Express on the route but
not in shoes that's the rt-pcr and also
this did real-time pcr and see the
induction of nipple one dash two is
brushing by aluminum so after four hours
of illuminant treatment so it reached
the maximum level and decrease of the
bit and also nip one digital expression
is specifically induced by aluminum
treatment are not by other metal or
stress as well so by the low pH
treatment so here's the teachers the
Pacific localization of nip one touch
tools of this because analysis so you
can see nipawin s2 is made it is breast
in the root hip region of other made the
primary and lateral and so also the you
see the gas stadiums was enhanced by
illuminant cheetahmen so you can see
they are not only enhance also by the
region I mean going up and down so
what's the feel of life or for the nip
one dash two mutant in in terms of
aluminum torrance so here shows that the
nip one digital is that we acquire three
independent t-dna insertion line from
abrc and can see all of them are
hypersensitive to to aluminum treatment
compared to the wild-type so here's the
wild thyme and that a significant
decrease of the ruger for two
representative line
and so we try to understand the
Magnusson's why nip one touch to its can
and it's a function in illuminant
tolerance so one thing is we measure I
mean staying on the wild-type and nip
one touch to mutant with hematoxylin so
this is the time that stained illuminant
in the cell were only in the server but
not in the cytosol but we can see
there's almost no staining without
illuminant a stone staining in the root
tip region for the wild-type but the the
strength of the staining much are higher
in the mutant line so that suggests as
more aluminum was accumulated in the
mutant than the wild-type so here is the
quantification for this our experiment
we see are compared to the wild type and
the mutant the mutant tends to
accumulate more aluminum in the site as
our server but in the site also it
reverse I mean we see less illuminant
was transported into the cytosol that
suggests I mean nibble one dash two is a
illuminant transporter responsible for
update of aluminum into the cytosol
so here's the working model for for this
part yeah so the end nip one touch to
responsible for aluminum uptake from
cell wall or from the rhizosphere and
then moved to to the pair cycle through
the sink plastic flow so we don't know
if and nip one dash two is also
responsible for the silent update or it
could but it could have some other
components are definitely it's are
involved in the illuminant translocation
from blue to shoe I didn't show this why
I mean we found that actually the
aluminum content in the shield for the
mutant it's less than than the end of
the world well tied yes service like
summarized Arab top 6 aluminum Lawrence
actually a publicist has adopt the
exclusion Magnuson so that's involved
the release of mail a sea change and
also we demonstrate that are the truth
torrance magazines also functioning air
toxics and also are in charge engines
group in judging university they have
done lot of work on the silver part so
so it's a small plan is we're not very
current to illuminant but it has arms
every no mechanisms for abdomen
resistance okay the last part i will
briefly report on our recent progress in
dissecting regulatory pathways are
involved in be sitting through low pH
and illuminant stress in arabidopsis
so in epilepsy in camas group they
identify a mutant they're highly
sensitive too long pH so only two lo lo
pierde that's that what they screen are
for and they columbus gene it they
called a stop one its encode a single
finger transcription factor actually
it's a master transcription factor that
control many of our the null we're in
the very know illuminant resistant gene
like a 80 amt one that's a male a
transporter and a teammate a suture
transporter and a 03 are so very
important but we don't know exactly how
they function so probably its function
in the junction of aluminum torrents and
phospho deficiency resistance so it's a
master signal transcription factor
factor so in this part is this work is
led by faith young with a two-year
visiting our graduate students very
amazing as he as you can see in later
sir has made a lot of progress so the
vcr diagram the possible signaling
pathway for our for the stubborn
controlled system so we we know a stub
one if you're not going on it's
hypersensitive to low pH but also all
these genes are not done knock out n and
there's also hypersensitive sensitive to
aluminum toxicity but we know these two
process are independent the reasons that
all of this mutant they are not
hypersensitive to low pH so they are
separated so and in this world that we
try to find are the some component in
any of this
pathway so we're using traditional our
classic genetics to screen revertants
for the as the stop one phenotype
genotype so here the reason I'm in this
wild hide under low pH and the stubborn
mutants hypersensitive to to to low pH
and this disturb one revert and you see
our it's not completely reverted but as
eighty percent over seventy percent are
reverting in terms of root growth and
here's some of the putative Milton for
the Riverton and then we try to test
their response to different stress one
are like alumina you see some of that
the militant it's actually it's more
resistant through our two aluminum
compared to the are its parent line and
some of them's hypersensitive to Saudi n
and resistant to cadmium compared to the
even to the wild-type some other things
are very sensitive to academy and so
they are we don't know what what's going
on mouth and then our faith young
decided to clone one of these genes
aways the nests gem sequencing
approaches so this the the riverton and
across with the stop one mutant and in
in the app to population supported long
road was the short route and is Jack DNA
make a library sequencing unless gen
sequencing and can find are putative
snip to associate with a different
phenotype
and the last step would be our very feel
very finely if that's really the cause
paper snip so here's the the result the
wild type and the hypersensitive of stop
one and blue gloves at the lung pH and
this dr the river turned so i also we
know this gene and we can order the
t-dna insertion line on this for this
gene and actually the t-dna it's not
sensitive to our to low ph s so what if
we incorporate the t-dna the dis mutant
into the stubborn background could we
see any riverton phenotype as the are
the ems mute mute mutant mutation yeah
actually it is i mean there's almost no
difference between the ems generated
mutant and the t-dna insertion mutant in
the stub one back one so pretty much we
think we are find out this thing and
finally that's the last slide and i
would like to first think Leah yeah
that's i mean i can express more my is
our operation for hims of us I what we
think I say posted honestly mention and
also he hire me as I syi and work on
this project I mean we have ten years
work experience but I'm sorry he's
living but i think we are still
collaborator makers color
up in a few creature and here's the work
i mean i remember in the group that work
in this project i'm sorry i cannot
present out of their work and also jung
and arab his also thanks for the
collaborator and the fund funding agency
and also i can so this the michael he
worked for the most of the protein part
award and ye cheese he liked the knit
one digital project and feel his a
two-year visiting graduate student from
chinese academy of science so so he
severely i mean in the summer but he led
the the stop one Riverton project so
it's very amazing at every two years
yeah thank you for your attention so I
would like to answer questions are any
indication that
there's sort of signal from the shoot
coming back down ah that's a tough
question yeah believe you haven't
blinking that yeah now I don't know it
could be but mainly I mean we are the
toxicity of aluminum it's ready target
idly drove through the region actually
shoot is much much less sensitive to to
a luminous chest and some kind I love
some of the grand species life are the
alumina accumulator like tea party they
actually like a story of a group bactrim
in in the soil environment but the day
is like obtained large amount of an
ordinary from the Sawyer and in
translocated into the shoe like a vacuum
out of chute issues i I don't I mean I
don't know how this shoes signal cannon
coming back to him yeah I'll be more
important work for the room that you if
knowing your your field of research
making the noxious signal but
photosynthate for the citric acid Lisa
we've always wondered in you get to work
on acetate go into those rooms I think
you finally look at that where are going
to have up we can see 11 labeled lacks
ambition 100 and sleeker image the
carbon coming folks if they go into the
roots and same time we can image you
know roots a challenge i'm alumina-man
CPAC or say just a specific see if that
chain affectionately see because i
always wondered is that might turn on i
want a single to photosynthate so if you
are losing although the plant is
considered minimize how much it loses by
head I just met little areas but it's
something we're going to look at how
much is it but what about apartments
being exported into the soil so we
haven't I don't like if you have any
quantification but are actually really
saw indirectly yeah the carbon lost
actually affect blue grouse yet because
we have the old expression line for the
melee are situated east and without
aluminum so the growth actually is nice
good has the damn catchy a decline such
as I think it has some luck yeah
definite has a negative impact on the
google so very suspicious priestess
organ think we really localized whatever
absolutely more spread out so ready
have an ounce of overexpressing
transporters without a little bit still
release depend on six train but I'll
follow that route you know I think the
biggest the most dramatic or me to you
know example of this goes there lupines
under on yet efficiency that in the very
roots they can at least thirty percent
of the cargo pacific but that's not a
problem at though you know it's there
it's just surprised it's like they're a
silly question but does the winnipeg
roads and acidic conditions does the ph
of the epidermal cells in the rear
change does it drop my pw mean oh yeah I
mean to go for lunch invested a lot of
morphological Johnny under par quality
of the pH does it be a solid
relationship central yeah i mean that's
that's the tough question so we're
really wondering what what's the PAH
what's the form of a luminary being
transport are from Somalia to our cycles
are definitely aluminum if that has to
be at the low pH meter la moneda
properly the micro environment could be
very different so it has to be abnormal
cells seem like the interface that
numbers have to be a set of
the effect will happen yeah think about
your asset kicks you got that's the
tracing of ph 7.4 second so what's
actually being released as the face was
I valid on the outside but once it comes
out it's given any extra money for this
is something I yelled at Martian about
in his text actually I have a photograph
from 0 to aldi I remember them none of
us are right off the tiger isn't like
that because he says organic ass release
acidifies and it doesn't because you're
not releasing the acid releasing the
base is already lost its protons in the
cytoplasm say anything in my treason
which I by releasing that protons in the
cytoplasm it acidifies the that recent
the cytoplasm you think and then there
is a very quiet
some sometimes seem to prefer a sort of
pH like blueberries
it is a blueberry for the preferred own
well-being I mean some of them are ya a
little could have some beneficial if
that I have got some paperwork teacher
PE yeah that's all sir I had by the
paper that they are aluminum
accumulation in teas mostly the old be
so you by T by good quality but I
explain the behavior of the bridge
so no I'm the key in China growing
around Suzanne university that's an
absolute I said ya esta saya holding as
I look at that screeching source of
fresh young lady yeah I mean the young
girl evening joining this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu